we can now hear I think from Teresa may
she's been speaking after that meeting
with Donald Tusk let's listen to what
the Prime Minister has just had to say
know what I've been doing here in Europe
over the past day is actually doing what
I promised Parliament that I would do
which is to speak to other leaders in
Europe about the concerns Parliament
have raised about the backstop and I had
breakfast with Prime Minister Rutter
sought Chancellor Merkel over lunch I'm
seeing presidents a Tuscan Juncker this
evening and what has been shown to me
from those meetings is that there is a
shared determination to deal with this
issue and address this problem and I'm
going to be seeing the teashop knee over
adkar tomorrow and then on Thursday
returning to the EU Council at the deal
we've negotiated is a deal that honors
the referendum it honors the result of
the referendum and it's the best deal
available indeed it's the only deal
available and the backstop which is the
issue that Parliament has raised the
backstop is a necessary guarantee for
the people of Northern Ireland and
whatever outcome you want whatever
relationship you want with Europe in the
future there's no deal available that
doesn't have a backstop within it but we
don't want the backstop to be used and
if it is we want to be certain that it
is only temporary and it's those
assurances that I will be seeking from
fellow leaders over the coming days so
that was a no you haven't been told
about this 48 plus letters or you have
been told no I have been here in Europe
dealing with the issue which I promised
Parliament I would be dealing with which
is the backstopping Northern Ireland and
the backstop for Northern Ireland which
is in the withdrawal agreement talking
to fellow leaders about the concerns
that Parliament have raised I have seen
a shared determination to deal with this
issue the backstop is a guarantee to the
people of Northern Ireland but we want
to know that it can only be temporary if
it is brought into use and it is those
assurances that I would be seeking over
the coming days but from those same
leaders and officials we'd be meeting
here in Brussels what we've had this
emphatically be renegotiated given that
and the fact you haven't been able to
put the withdrawal agreement to the vote
in the Commons in tomorrow's cabinet
meeting will you be stepping up the No
Deal preparations
we have already stepped up the No Deal
preparations that has been happening in
recent in recent days but cabinet will
be discussing what is the sensible thing
for government to do which is to make
sure that those contingency arrangements
of No Deal preparations are in place so
we will be looking at what further what
further more we need to do in relation
to those No Deal preparations but what
I'm discussing with European leaders and
we'll continue to discuss with them is
how we can provide that assurance that
the backstop for Northern Ireland were
it to be used and it doesn't need to be
used but where it be used it we need
certainty that is only temporary any
idea at the end of the day whether we're
any closer to a date for the vote to be
put is it going to be well ahead of
Jeremy the 21st in December can you give
any assurance on that front now what I
have started today is the discussions
with other fellow leaders in Europe
about this issue of course we do have
the 21st of January date that you've
referenced which Parliament has set so
we need to look at this issue before
then but we're just at the start of the
negotiations and the start of the
discussions